l'adaptation sans cesse à la situation
sanitaire la recherche d'un équilibre
entre prudence et confiance et le
souhait constant de ne pas imposer des
restrictions une seconde de trop aux
français à ce titre un conseil de
défense et de sécurité nationale s'est
réunie ce matin je le disais consacrée à
l'épidémie de kovy de 19 il a acté une
adaptation territoriale de plusieurs
mesures de freinage ainsi à partir du
lundi 4 octobre dans les départements où
le taux d'incidence se stabilise au
dessous du seuil de 50 pour cent mille
habitants le protocole scolaire passera
en niveau 1 ce qui signifie
essentiellement que l'obligation du port
du masque à l'école primaire il sera
levé deuxième mesure les jauges qui
s'applique dans certains établissements
recevant du public seront levés dans ces
mêmes départements se